[Music]
in text back news submitted by Goku son
a tech-savvy father built a smartphone
app that forces kids to reply the
messages oh hello
oh it should talk everything yeah right
if you don't respond and you can't
access her instagrams yeah that's pretty
much how it works
oh so it blow everything your phone I
love that you have to reply to the
message for it to go away and it also
played the sound and it won't stop
playing until you reply want to give it
to Bart why reply immediately if I don't
wanna reply to my dad like where are you
I'm just gonna send a bunch of smiley
faces just bypass it you know those red
things on the text that tells you how
many text is you have to answer it just
keeps going up oh I can't do that I know
that that drives me nuts like my emails
they're all down to zero oh my - I'll
tell you right now he has like 2,000
emails and I'm like whoa twenty one
thousand eight hundred and eighty two
emails 245 group me notifications three
we're off thirteen text messages twenty
weeks - for Pandora one for Netflix yeah
I have to I have to delete the ones that
makes me feel popular I'll get you later
I'm busy
there are coupons the [ __ ] feet
robbing and [ __ ] but the bypass adapting
like every time takes I'm worried since
then a bunch of [ __ ] ass like
gibberish just a bypass it's a good sign
eyes my [ __ ] yeah well then get me he'll
just keep texting I mean [ __ ] yeah
that's annoying
I think it's [ __ ] genius
I like that too actually yeah so this
app is called reply asap - boy stop
[ __ ] your girlfriend you need to come
home for dinner your mom's looking for
you possibly goes I saw your play seven
o'clock on the dot
you better not be high still cuz it's
time to come home
yes he created it for his 13 year old
son perfect age this kind of what it
looks like and so here are some features
getting stoned on top is on top is who
do you want to send an ace up to send it
to dad and then it says what's once a
message will be audible even at the
phone silent dope what I remind you the
bbm buzzing sounds cool noise continue
until it is acknowledged does like me
when I [ __ ] needy whoever I'm dating
mm-hmm message will appear over what is
over on the screen what whatever is on
the screen
buying a bundle will allow you to gift
app to people you want to send messages
to so that's the one thing that is
getting a lot of negative reviews on the
App Store so first of all it's only
available for Android for now they're
working on making available app for
Apple nobody cares about Android I care
about androids for the mock-up I know
[Music]
five this whole bundle thing so you have
to pay a certain amount of monies if for
you to send it to one person or three
people or five people or 10 people per
message and that's what I wanted to find
out a plea you can get the app to
someone I that's what I'm assuming no
I'm not sure cuz they call it a plan so
it could be a monthly thank you I'm not
really too sure sure I was trying to
find out too but since I don't have
Android okay send message straight away
or select the future time ability to
send from iOS to Android and vice versa
once iOS version launches no cost for
sending messages oh maybe maybe two I
guess the end of confirmation shown to
sender what message is read oh you know
what I see this being used as the
[ __ ] crazy-ass possessive boyfriends
or girlfriends
right there yeah yeah that's a good way
to keep tabs on each other what if there
is a way to bypass it mmm how no all you
got to do it by yourself won't leave
that cell phone at home break up with
that bitch-ass [ __ ] that keeps
on keeping you on tab yeah drinking with
your dad sorry [ __ ] off that's all you
gotta do is just disconnect from the
Wi-Fi and you won't receive it oh it
doesn't work on data apparently not
that's its own Wi-Fi yeah cuz kids can
connect to a school Wi-Fi weather
station Internet so that's one thing or
you can just turn off your SMS receiving
and then you won't get it so there is a
way to go around it there's another way
to if your kids don't answer fast and
when they get home you [ __ ] them up yeah
just beaten yeah the old-school way yeah
and then they won't make that same
mistake that's the old-school asian app
right there yeah yeah you don't answer
my mother doesn't reply asap
this is beating a set when mommy gives
you the page you don't go to the
payphone and company $19.99 [ __ ] right
there
that's struggle I gotta I had to [ __ ]
rush like [ __ ] was a payphone [ __ ]
wall skating she doesn't want me to call
collect yeah oh yeah we I went back and
forth from skateboard and rollerblade I
was by roller sexuals yeah cuz be more
like the spider gate still alive skate
sure like the skateboarders were like oh
you brought a blade that's so GA why and
then the other guys were like oh my god
skateboard is that's so old and I'm like
I did both hmm
beef back then yeah does Isaac have a
phone he doesn't have like a phone per
se but we do we bought him this little
it's like a little cube and it has a
speaker on it and has capability so all
it has is one button and so he can press
it once and
send a notification to my phone saying
that he's thinking of me oh alright if
you press and hold like if he holds it
for a while then they'll send me like a
urgent notification saying Isaac wants
you to call him right now so then I'm
able to call him from the school knowing
this little thing has like phone
capability so I never knew started
things actually were like they actually
get me never do a couple of things from
Kickstarter and I'm always disappointed
this one I like that's cool
VI man so he can't hang up on me only I
can hang up on him though I can listen
to a GPS there's GPS I could be on that
app sounds like it's made for kids huh
yeah that's me so that's why I bought
him that because I don't want him
telling me that he wants a cell phone
and because he doesn't need that he's
only nine and I'm like I don't want to
deal with it I just try to jack off the
porno I don't want any of my face on
that it's scary man like I was looking
up like there's like these kids games
and stuff but there's messaging and like
perverts get on there yeah roblox and I
yeah can't play roblox unless I'm with
you yeah and I better not catch you
messaging anybody cuz what's wrong
Bronks it's like a cheap-ass minecraft
game oh it was like having fun with
perverts on there I've seen this it's
like everyone it's like a world like a
virtual world where everyone has their
own characters and they run really
nation and people create games to be
placed on roblox I don't know I saw an
article about it by like perverts
messaging that's [ __ ] up cuz when I
was used to cyber sex all the time and
adults better watch out cuz I'm out I'm
I'm all up in that instant messenger
yeah their chicken beauty I remember -
it was like 12 or 13 nice to say I was
16 because I felt so old like let me
live it but like I can't lie that much
okay good I'm when you're younger
seventeen but I was really 12 I want to
look at that thing that's so cool what
if I was cyber sexy with my future kids
they'll probably have better ones in the
future oh for sure they will could baby
one that I bought Isaac already doesn't
like them call it customer service I
don't know for some reason it won't turn
off this I'm like well how do you do it
and then the GPS is messed up the GPS
says that Isaac's still in Atlanta for
some reason like what the hell
wait had a layover doesn't have like a
phone plan yes or I haven't I haven't
started paying for it yet because since
I bought it through Kickstarter they
gave me like six months free so cool oh
you ever plan on getting him like a
legit like phone phone what do you think
50 yeah I don't know I should think I
should just chip him or you can give him
a dump like a dog yeah just chip his ass
and then you'll never worry you know
everywhere he's gonna be somewhere on
the phone once I tell him like once you
show me that you're responsible and you
do all your chores without me having to
tell you and like you have good grooming
habits and damn you know you're good in
school like what he does habits yeah I
mean he's not he's like learning me me
starting I started caring about it in
junior high when I wanted to impress
girls yeah learn about Cologne that's
what I learned about all that dude that
just for dating that's it but he's such
a good kid though cuz I told him like
all right from now on this happened like
two weeks ago like from now on every
single day you need a shower whether you
or whether you come back for school like
I'm tired of letting you get off by
saying Abbi oh yeah
boy now like you've gotta shower dude so
then for his first phone do you plan on
giving him like a dumb phone like yes
nokia block I'm late like this [ __ ]
old last one would snake on it that's
all he gets that's like a sigh thank you
no I might as well just let him still
have the snow fox then or something
similar to that because I know the queen
of cool having a smartphone and like all
he needs with capabilities of
communicating with me he does classmates
have legit phones now I don't know I'm
just scared of like how easy it is to
get porn these days because like boys
are gonna be boys and they're gonna try
to jack off to everything but the more
real [ __ ] you get the more difficult it
is to leave the room so he's gonna have
you got you gotta talk to him or Casey
guy talk to him be like hey check it out
man you know this is fun now but your
dicks gonna get sore and then you're
gonna get bored of the normal [ __ ] and
then you're gonna want to [ __ ] a donkey
yeah I don't care about porn like right
now I'd like maybe I like 14 15 yeah
that's the part I'm normal that's normal
line that's when I'm like grooming him
come on go to Subway exactly teenager is
porn that's [ __ ] normal [ __ ] that's
true what up all my positive people I
want to hear your thoughts put it in the
comments below because if you're
negative shut the hell up and go drink
some raid please but if you're very
positive leave it in the comments below
for the last video over here
[Music]